buenos días bueno en principio
es una corriente que se está dando
prácticamente en toda latinoamérica
la salida en ya en primera vuelta de los
partidos tradicionales ocurrió en chile
seguramente vaya a ocurrir algo de eso
en argentina el próximo año y creo que
es una tendencia que se viene dando a
nivel latinoamericano que es un desgaste
de la política tradicional no en muchos
sentidos no principalmente creo que en
el término de los objetivos creo que la
población en los países de latinoamérica
percibe que no se han podido alcanzar
los objetivos que la política ha
prometido en estas últimas décadas y eso
en algún momento se paga y eso creo que
es lo que está sucediendo hoy en día
mayormente en latinoamericano un gran
desgaste gonzalo hablemos en particular
del fenómeno de rodolfo hernández un
candidato que al final pues remontó y se
quedó en esta segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales desbancando al
favorito para pasar una segunda vuelta
con gustavo petro
estamos hablando de fico gutiérrez
bueno acá es básicamente un apéndice de
lo que estoy diciendo para que esto
suceda también se necesita la generación
de nuevos líderes que prácticamente
terminan viniendo digamos alguna manera
fuera del sistema o con poca experiencia
en el sistema no como el caso de
hernández no yo creo que básicamente en
él estamos viendo la representación de
esto mismo que digo podría haber sido es
lo podría haber sido cualquier otra
persona y termina generando un
crecimiento muy rápido no hernández
termina logrando prácticamente en vez de
abrir un crecimiento de siete puntos y
ahora
elecciones de por medio fuera de lo que
ya son las encuestas se percibe otro 7%
más que lo termina dejando en
prácticamente ese 28 por ciento y en
crecimiento porque acá lo importante de
todo es básicamente ver las tendencias y
hacia dónde va cada uno en un corto
plazo porque la segunda vuelta realmente
no da tiempo para para trabajar es muy
corta como la mayoría de los países y
creo que no va a poder variar muy poco
desde lo que vimos este ayer hasta la
próxima segunda vuelta no que tendría
que hacer en esta segunda vuelta el
candidato usado petro para finalmente
ganarle teniendo en cuenta que federico
gutiérrez ya expresó públicamente su
apoyo al candidato rodolfo hernández y
también l dijo 'todos electorado que
votaran por él haciendo esa suma a
grandes rasgos pues evidentemente es
rodolfo fico suma más votos que petro
que tiene que hacer petro para tener
esos votos y poder ganar así en la
segunda vuelta
y esa es una muy buena pregunta y yo me
lo planteé con nuestra elección aquí en
uruguay fue muy similar la izquierda
voto el 39% casi lo mismo que petro y
los partidos digamos en coalición que
estaban en contra de lo que es el frente
amplio que es la izquierda en uruguay
sumaban el 53 por ciento o sea una
situación muy similar a la que tiene
colombia hoy ahora cuál fue la
diferencia en su momento para la segunda
vuelta que esos partidos que estaban
coalición a dos tuvieron alguna pérdida
de votos y votaron al
48% se ganó la elección pero con muy
poco con lo cual para petro va a ser muy
difícil subir ese ese yo le llamaría
casi techo
pues todo está por verse entonces
gonzalo en esta segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales colombianas
gracias por su tiempo un gran abrazo de
ceuta